[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
where we are currently off the record
wow really how does that like run the
course don't say [ __ ] guys he does it
really really sweet dreams of being a
lawyer
i didn't i don't know we are currently
off the record
objection today's record
is what how did you first ask your girl
out really
did you say ask your or eat your girl
what'd you say oh come on man
i feel you brother this guy huh
what an animal
so i [ __ ] hannah the first 15 minutes
that i've seen her really yeah that's
gay so how did that go that was probably
the record let's start with that go
ahead walk us through it can i can i can
i complete joe bingo did she eat your
ass too not the first night okay
no no not the first time that you guys
were physically like face to face i'm
talking about like how did you even get
face to face oh well the lead-up the
build-up to it yeah we've been talking
online for like
at least like
five tell us the story like yeah we're
like
go to the beginning okay oh no no we're
not hand
okay oh this is how it happened
tarantino style my first trip to london
um it was christmas time right and
during that time i love the holidays
whenever i travel a lot of people dm me
like because it's like oh you're in my
town try this try that it always [ __ ]
happens and then because at the time i
was doing hella food blogs uh a lot of
people would send restaurants of their
favorites right
so when i was in london they're like i
know what you guys are thinking you
always say that londoners have [ __ ] [ __ ]
food this is what you gotta choose you
still think yeah and i still think that
so i kept going getting the
recommendations putting it in my excel
file right
and then hannah was one of the few that
was like all right everybody says london
food sucks uh try these chinese
restaurants or whatever and i'm like
these are some good picks
and i was like why don't you come out
and go eat it with me right she goes oh
i can't i'm in a different city and i'm
like that's fine you knew she was a girl
at this time not really so you were just
down for anybody that dm me to go meet
she seemed pretty cool yeah yeah but
there were but also she was just a pfp
you didn't know this girl but you said
come out and eat with me yeah i mean
well yeah keep keep in mind i made two
guy friends in london too
that are fans joe just likes hanging bro
joe's easy hand i've made like what
awesome guys i do meet and greets and i
don't [ __ ] all of them surprisingly
right you've never [ __ ] a male fan
[ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] all my fans yeah hey you
know who does uncle roger uncle roger
and he's a london
guy it's a secret man guys don't just
okay like like you you're into fighting
right yeah you don't like when you're
traveling don't you go to like a local
mma gym and be like yeah and i [ __ ] all
them too bro i [ __ ] all of this but the
point top to bottom bro
i think
i actually use social media like normal
people use social media and i have
friends like i make friends on social
media over common interests or whatever
the thing about hannah right her page
was um
it was like textures and pictures so
it's kind of feminine but there were
groups of girls
and there was no picture of herself
because this was her professional
instagram uh and it was like fashion and
[ __ ] and it was like dresses and clothes
and [ __ ] like that so yeah obviously
like you know it was a girl but i didn't
know which one it was out of the the
group
but
we were talking for like
she wasn't in the same city i went to
central europe all this we just kept
chatting i went to vietnam or i went to
all these different places on a vietnam
came before that i went to uh hawaii and
all these different places and then we
just kept chatting until one day she
sent me a video
and i was like oh [ __ ] this girl's
actually pretty [ __ ] cute dude what
the hell
but before that it was always just memes
and jokes what was the video oh wait so
when you asked her to go eat with you
she didn't come out to you with you that
one time she wasn't even in the same
city i think she was in liverpool at the
time yeah what was the video i've had
bro dates though okay in in london with
with fans we heard about darien for a
long time all right yeah darian wasn't
there but yeah my friend darian
i just think it's interesting at least
from my point of view because i'm not an
extrovert so i enjoy privacy so like
when i go places i just like i'm in like
my own bubble doing my whole thing so
keep in mind that the the the time i was
there i i ditched one of the dudes that
i went out there with because i had and
then i hadn't i didn't have no friends i
had to change my plans
um i made two friends there that [ __ ]
rescued me from the shitty uh adventure
and um they were you know they they knew
who jk was or whatever but we were all
at the club mutual friends right there
was one guy who's kind of a i don't know
how to describe him he was himself he's
kind of a moderator he was weird he we
kicked them out right but what what
happened was those two guys one of them
he's from the czech republic so he went
home early because this was christmas
week so everyone was spending time with
family the other one had plan plans with
family so i was basically alone for like
a week and that's when i was just like
yo who wants to chill and in that club
we went to um all as a group the club
owner i became friends with too and he
took me out for one of the nights and so
like at that time i was just basically
desperate for friends because i just
didn't want to spend you know christmas
week alone and [ __ ]
and then uh what ended up happening was
the guy that went to the czech republic
he was like hey why don't you guys just
[ __ ] come to my house and spend
christmas with me and then so we went
out there and so um
that whole time i never met her
for the whole year we just kept chatting
back and forth when when she sent me a
video of her and her friends just on
production she was just like chilling
laughing like and she was sending me
like voice memo or like video memo and i
was like oh [ __ ] she's [ __ ] kind of
cute and so we went and chatted and all
this stuff and then
um you know it got pretty serious and
she was like when you come to london i'm
like i don't know they're just like text
flirting yeah i was just text flirting
right and then my buddy he's been dating
a girl out there for like four years and
then so he gets an apartment and he's
like yeah man i'm gonna be out there
like i'm gonna be bored all [ __ ] day
so if you want to come through come
through i got like three bedrooms and i
was like oh hell yeah i'll [ __ ] pitch
in let's do it
so i was like hey i guess i'm coming to
london and then she goes okay and then
by that time we were flirting we were
talking sexual all that stuff so phone
you're [ __ ] doing pov videos i was
jacking off like a [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] giving her a little
taste of what your [ __ ] is gonna be
like pretty soon yeah yeah yeah so by
the time um you know is that true
yeah hell yeah dude oh yeah everything
bro
i'm a i'm
i'm a sex lover dude not a haver but six
positives not negative
i'm very sex positive yeah
by that time i think we were already
like super
you know intense because um when i like
someone i think i just get hooked and i
don't i mean i don't know like i had
other girls lined up because i was like
you know what if i'm going to go out
there who knows dude god damn so
romantic this is the honest truth right
who knows if i'm going to go half
halfway across the world who [ __ ]
knows if this one's gonna be dope right
yep you might as well line up some other
to just hang with yeah well who knows
what's gonna happen like a plan b out
there plan b c and z right wow you just
don't know 26 of them lined up because i
don't want to be the dude that just ends
up and i guess stood up and then there's
like no one else to like i'm just like
in london and i have my friend and that
night like he's just blowing the hell
out of his girlfriend and like who whose
face am i gonna sit on right exactly or
whose face is gonna sit on me oh i was
thinking about your butt going on there
on their face you're going to sit on my
face you're who's facing my concern yeah
you're right you're right
so technicalities he's a face sitter so
the thing is like i see her um
uh first thing we do we [ __ ] walk
upstairs
and then i don't know how this happened
but we go straight to the shower
straight to [ __ ] all of all of that
and then we we [ __ ] before our first
date
we [ __ ] and then we went on our date
and then we we went to eat italian food
and how was the first time were you just
like wow this chick is cool man yeah we
were connecting
what was the food we both were uh we
were both just like it was supposed to
be a hookup
it was just like i mean come on man like
it's london like how the [ __ ] am i gonna
date somebody that far you know yeah so
even the flirting then
it none of it got deep it was sexual and
um the the conversations were long
because it was so intellectually dope
so it was like yeah you know just have
fun with someone and then it's not too
deep you know if it's not too deep then
it's like not committed and you can
explore a lot and have a lot of fun just
shooting the [ __ ] she was obviously
really like thankful too because she was
like i can't believe you're taking me to
a bucket of betpo
should have never had italian before
can we get the cheesy bread we had
american style italian food
by italians from italy american style
yeah that's what they are it was the
weirdest [ __ ] they had they had
mannequins of dictators
on different tables who was your
favorite the kim jong-il one
yeah they had a [ __ ] dictator just
sitting and i was like so what do they
do when they want to see four people
they just have a mannequin of a dictator
just sitting there it was the [ __ ]
oddest [ __ ] yeah was the food good it
was good yeah yeah it was good but it
was just so weird um but yeah that was
like the quickest i think one of the
quickest ways uh i don't know that i'm
not i'm thinking back no that's not true
i've had other one night stand so i feel
like you're being kind of you're kind of
withholding from the story you're in the
shower take us through like what
happened like minute one you get in the
shower go ahead we drop our clothes
we're flagging making out getting out
getting in the shower we're [ __ ]
scrubbing the [ __ ] out each other
and then like you guys use your loofahs
or just bare hands at this point where
did she go for your calzone
i don't remember at that point at that
point i think we just it went straight
to the [ __ ] bed and we already have
we didn't even wipe ourselves off
completely and it's just still covered
in suds yeah and i think my friend was
in the other room [ __ ] taking a nap
or something
yeah and then that was that but the
sexual chemistry was on point is what
you're saying it was fire man i haven't
had solid sex in a in a minute yeah yeah
but that was cool so just call everybody
and that was a little fan this too a
little fan dish as well but when i have
good sex with fans in a minute when did
it go from that to hey let's try to have
a relationship so wholesome question i
like that i would say
maybe after we spent the night i i just
didn't even want to meet
any other girls i was kind of that's
when you texted plan b to z and you're
like [ __ ] off a lot of text copy and
paste this is why we're we're we're buds
because we're i'm the same as you
it's just a curse dude so to me like the
other part of me was like maybe i should
just try yeah because who knows like you
have to compare but also it would taint
what i got
like once you do it's like you can't
really go back because you broke that
that that sacredness
and i wanted to because you know i just
want to feel different titties you know
it's just variety you told me you
promised me you said as brothers you
said i will get my dick sucked by two
strikes at the same time and i'll do it
for you steve you didn't [ __ ] do it i
still can you fell for the first chick
yeah and ruined it and here you wasn't
the first but i i still can
hey
you just need to fulfill that promise i
will you swore to me i will i will not
your word what made you want to swear to
that i don't know it was weird i just
had to do it
because steve said you're he's like i
better be the first one out of all your
friends to when if you get a double blow
job it better be me that's what he said
i'm like i will i will i will i'm not
even gonna text i will personally call
you right after i nut
in my nut voice it's literally the most
romantic story ever
he did tell me i'm not kidding he
actually told me that no i believe you
guys 100
um because that was my thing like before
i because i was like oh [ __ ] me and my
ex we broke up oh [ __ ] yeah it's about
to be on about the head [ __ ] multiple
chicks at the same time probably lesbian
women who want to be turned
uh yeah
i feel like i had my whole face though
in between it was really fun it was hard
during kovid
but i mean
yeah but dude you had some chicks pick
you up yes
and drop you off
they lifted me up and by my butt cheeks
and [ __ ] nah
wait did that really happen yeah i did
like steve was right there just watching
because memorable
so bart you met you got with geo how
does that how does that go down
same way 15 minutes we're just [ __ ]
yeah
now ours is um ours is interesting
because this is like way long time ago
right this is like what
we've been we got together in 2008 so
this is haven't you guys been friends
for like decades before yeah yeah so
this is like 14 years ago
and then three years before that he was
dating my friend
and we were all in the same group
together um but me and her didn't really
get along i thought she was a [ __ ] she
didn't like me that was annoying
and um
when they broke up the group still hung
out and then we went used to go
snowboarding a lot
and there's this one time it was
supposed to be a bunch of us meet up at
her house
and then we're all gonna go snowboarding
we go there
and then it ends up just being me and
him me and her i texted everyone else
and you showed up an hour early
yeah yeah and i text everyone else and
uh no one else was
was uh picking up and so we're like do
we still want to go oh [ __ ] let's go
so we go we head towards big bear
and out of nowhere um it gets snowed in
and it's if you go to big bear it's like
a two-way street yeah it gets snowed in
to the point where it's just a pile up
and then everyone has to turn their car
off wow the perfect condition yeah it
was crazy come on man so we're like all
right so i guess we're stuck here and it
was kind of awkward because we didn't
really talk like that
and then we just started talking and
then it just turned into like a
four-hour conversation and then um we're
like oh [ __ ] like you're actually way
different once you get once we get to
know each other we felt felt that both
ways
so we went uh when it cleared up we went
snowboard when we came back um we wanted
to go again and this time was it was our
intention to go again
and um i think it has always been like
this weird like
i don't know like taboo thing where you
don't really like date your friends exes
but then me and with that dude weren't
really friends anymore and also he
didn't let her have any friends so all
of her friends were just us that's weird
so that's why it felt weird to just like
after they break up to leave her alone
so everyone just felt like hey we should
we could all still be friends and kind
of like have you know like different
time to hang out like she'll have family
like thanksgiving like she'll go to one
of our closest friends house
to have like thanksgiving dinner because
that's just how tight the group was at
the time you know it was just like
um even after they broke up
and then so we started hanging out i
mean we planned a second snowboard trip
and then yeah it was kind of weird to
like traverse this
and um
i think after that when we started when
we came back and we started talking
online it was when we found out we both
kind of liked each other
and then i remember like this is uh this
is the christmas break
of college where i'm supposed to come
back and live at joe's pad and we're
supposed to write skits like every every
single day
and uh which we did but then i would
tell john oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] crazy
because joe's been friends with jio for
this whole time now but i think
we like each other and i remember he was
sending me all these songs like
forbidden lover like uh computer love
because i'm like because i'm like he's
[ __ ] with the fact that you weren't
supposed to it's a guy coach yeah yeah
and he was just like sending me all
these [ __ ] songs and [ __ ] and he was
like oh my god i can't believe it oh my
god
and then uh
yeah and then i think finally uh
me and girl like what's this thing we're
dancing around or whatever because it's
been like a month
so she said that first yeah she said
first you [ __ ] i know i was a [ __ ] and
then so we met and then we talked about
it and then um i think we
we told each other we liked each other
and then i had to go like well you know
before we take it any further even
though that fool's like not my homie
anymore i just don't like doing things
like i don't know weird i got to like
keep everything straight up so i i
texted my friend and then um i was like
hey can i talk to you about something
he's like sure
and then so i met up with him i told him
the whole thing and he goes ah you guys
you guys will never work out or whatever
and then i'm like
i'm like i was like all right i mean
that's you could say what you want
because you weren't really friends at
that point anymore you know but i just
wanted to say like i just wanted to hear
like let you know up front and then
that's dope how long has it been now
respect 14 years do you think he's still
like
they're gonna break up any minute now
[Applause]
and i was like so do i have your
blessing or what's going on he goes yeah
go do whatever you want because we're
not even like really friends at that
point goes yeah do it everyone and i'm
like all right cool
so that was that and then i think when
we came back um
that night um we ended up having sex the
first time and then
we got the blessing went straight to it
huh
and then uh it's like an old-time
traditional
and then
we just knew yes
day one from that point though maybe
because we've seen each other with other
chicks like i've been on double dates
with her with me and another chick and
her with that with the other dude and
like i'm [ __ ] on the beach and i
don't know what they're doing so i think
we've seen each other in relationships
for like three because kind of like you
and nicky a little bit where we've seen
each other in relationships for only
three or four years so it's like we know
the real each other because there's no
ulterior motive it's not like we're both
honeymoon and trying to impress each
other it's like we weren't trying to
[ __ ] each other on the side yeah like we
already know how we are and then so i
think all of that just clicked and then
day one of us officially being together
we're like i didn't want to go all the
way like we're gonna we'll probably end
up getting married so you get you [ __ ]
the first i go we're marrying yeah i
think we just kind of we just kind of
knew i think we just kind of when you
know you know though like it's just
[ __ ] easy me and nicky went on a date
i'll make it very quick we i i was at a
shoot with my butt so my my buddy
forever homie michael gallagher
uh totally sketched he hooked it up
where um so me and nikki
um we're gonna be in a sketch together
because i just gotten broken up with by
my ex and then um michael was hanging
out with nikki a couple nights later and
she's like steve green's single are you
[ __ ] kidding me i'm in love with
steve green
and then that's what nikki said yeah
great up told him that and then he's
like wait you like like him like him
she's like oh yeah and he's like oh i
don't think he's ready for that yet
and then why is he [ __ ] blocking well i
think he was being he's being a homie
actually just trying to set the table so
it wouldn't be too crazy so i could hook
up as much as i wanted to if i wanted to
but no so i end up going i end up i'm
not at this shoot with with uh with
nikki and michael writes this thing
where like me and her are supposed to
make out and so like we're like we're
making out like for like [ __ ] 20
seconds what a homie oh he's the best
dude what a dream he's my he's my best
friend
true scotty
right there yeah for real for real he's
my best he's better than scotty he's my
best man and i took that personally
no so so so we're um we're doing that
make out sketch and she kept on like
jumping on me too like it was like part
of what she was improvising was she
would kept jumping on me and i was like
god damn this chick is [ __ ] thick
[Laughter]
so then so then um we were on set and i
was like and we were talking about
movies or whatever i i like movies me
and michael write movies at school and i
was like yo like um
this movie great gatsby we kept talking
about it i was like you wanna go [ __ ]
see it and she's like yeah and i was
like cool it's on and then she texts my
buddy jason horton who i moved to l.a
with so he's like a really homemade a
real homie and i moved to koreatown with
him and and she's like do you think it's
a date and like apparently
unbelief to me i texted her within like
20 minutes and i was like yo
um i'm picking you up and next time
i'm buying you food it's a date
just to like [ __ ] really set the
table yeah what a g well because i
realized it was a little bit vague the
way that i set it up because we were in
the sketchbook that's nice to clear so
that's an important move if you're
interested in a chick you got to be like
hey this is a [ __ ] date state your
intent or if you're not then you'd be
like
you want to just hang out like that
exactly do you want to get coffee or
something
i'm not kidding once i confidently set
those terms i showed up on the date
and i just [ __ ] pissed all of myself
that's how you stick your clothes i just
[ __ ] peed like this and i'm so sorry
but people are the big type of people
that have a real people and then she
says oh let me clean it up it's for son
of a [ __ ]
i can change it i can fix them dude it
was the george mcfly
i fell in the street
no no so that so then you know i pick
her up and like the story goes like i
pick her up and then um i'm driving i'm
supposed to go to burbank
i drive south like i pick her up she's
in hollywood i'd drive south to go to
burbank
like i didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on because i saw so much
butterflies and so much so many things
you gotta put like a thomas guy drunk
yeah but then she's like do you know
where the [ __ ] you're going and i was
like
i was like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cause i was like
and then i didn't and then um
she's like yeah i don't think this is
where burbank is and so we ended up
getting there we had sushi we talked for
like [ __ ] four hours like you and geo
like in the in the ice storm thing and
dude it was on after that like she ended
up texting her friend she's like um her
friend's like hey how's it going because
she always knew that she wanted to go on
a date with me and stuff and then and
then nikki texts back the same night as
our first date she's like do you want
chicken or steak at the wedding wow
that's awesome and it's just like that
when you know you know man it's like all
the way on and i knew i'm not kidding
it's crazy i knew i was gonna marry this
woman i told michael that i was like yo
mike i was like can i ask her to marry
me or he's like you should [ __ ] hold
on
just hold on
i was like yo i'm ready he was like i'm
not kidding this is like in a week
and he's like you should hold up and
then i did for like you know
two years before i actually asked her
but i already knew she was down like
within like died
[Applause]
goddammit this chick is big
big
dick still is a great damn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you